hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
bar salal Mart Amazon or Spencer Gifts
play along with us let's go hey what's
up I'm Dan Soder I'm back to answer the
internet again make sure you check out
my HBO special son of a Gary airing
December 7th 10 p.m. on HBO and string
the [ __ ] out of it
first question would you rather wake up
to a blow job or $100 under your pillow
every morning 100 bucks
you don't know what kind of blow job if
you wake up every day to a toothy blow
job yeah that's a bad way to start
that's the opposite of a cup of coffee
unless you're a fighter and then what
and then which way what a great way to
wake up ready to put hands on people
like stop stop it what a yeah [ __ ] [ __ ]
up
would you rather fart only once a year
but it's the worst smell in the world
and you smell it for two weeks or fart
like you do now and it doesn't smell but
colored gas comes out of your ass I've
been waiting to do a color show I think
we should make something where you can
put it over your butt and it shoots
powder out in a colored form color toots
let's get on that can we get on that
technology but I would love to shoot
color out of my butt colored gas that'd
be great
like if it's different moods like what's
that Pixar movie where they're all the
different inside out it'd be like
inside-out farts we're like oh man you
like like why is it red you like you
know why you know why I'm [ __ ] mad at
you if you had the flexibility to blow
yourself would you I mean yeah what are
we doing here do you want me to go
through the rest of the question
fine what if everybody knew you did I'd
be like [ __ ] how long you know how
long of a jealous line that would be if
everyone knew I suck my own dick I
probably would put that I would change
my name to Dan I can suck my own dick
soda I'll put it on my driver's license
what I'm gonna name the bars though like
like you want to see it if I've to watch
me do I shake five to watch tender watch
me finish and then you'd have to watch
me boa constrictor oh my that is that
too graphic you get the picture would
you rather bang a bunch of models but
nobody knows or not actually [ __ ] them
but everyone think you did man Instagram
is broken everyone it's how do you of
course I'd rather bang a bunch of models
but no one knows I'm a gentleman
I would keep my secrets to myself names
and actions stay between us
in the sheets would you rather have to
heat up all your food and ten second
increments for the rest of your life or
dive Boehner first into a sidewalk one
time you know what this is a question
where you this is a this is a trap game
because you're like oh I got no ideology
I mean now you start thinking does your
does your boner break when you hit the
concrete is it just is it just the
bruise
cuz that's its inconvenience versus pain
come and take the pain I'll dive in
boner first one time if you could put
any franchise restaurant in your house
what would it be
Wendy's get your [ __ ] come on over come
on over Wendy's I want Frosty's for
breakfast for a second I thought you
know maybe do you want to do BK but the
king isn't nice but then I also thought
maybe like a nice Applebee's
you know have a sled on the wall really
Jersey up the place but Wendy's is
definitely it what's the worst what's
the worst thing you've gotten thrown out
of a bar for uh I think farting on a
lady I remember specifically being
hammered at a bar and thinking it was
funny that I was farting and then I
asked my friend's girlfriend if she
could feel the vibration cool cool feel
the vibration and then she was like it's
[ __ ] me Scott yeah then I got tossed
but I was also blackout and someone had
to tell me that story so if you were
murdered who would be the most like I
mean this is too real of a question cuz
I can answer some [ __ ] talking way yeah
if you were murdered who would be the
most likely suspect I feel like my mom
would set me up to get money and I would
that's why I love her and respect her
and that's why we always eat sitting at
corners with our backs to the wall
when old Sheriff what old sheriff's we
don't trust who's coming in that saloon
door Trisha and I always keep our backs
to each we done I'm like a mom
Merry Christmas you shifty [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] be cool be cool all right hands up
like it's a every time where you dinner
it's a mob meeting yeah all right does
your associate here did you check the
bathroom behind the toilet then we can
have a lovely turkey Tetrazzini if you
had to win a game show to stay alive
which game show would you choose si you
want it you want to have the big dick
energy and be like jeopardy but I'd get
[ __ ] smoked and then I'd be hurt and
dead I would say Wheel of Fortune but
I've smoked too much weed with that
words escape me I want to say oddly
enough Cash Cab shout-out Ben Bailey I
feel like with his love and support and
a couple [ __ ] you know a couple
lifelines I think I could do all right
no I would but I wouldn't do double or
nothing I wouldn't that's that's too
risky
I'm trying to I'm trying to you to quote
the great Jimmy V survive in advance if
you could wipe one group of people off
the earth who would it be this is a
great question and I already know the
answer it be anyone that texts on their
phone walking up the stairs of the
subway
you don't belong you don't belong here
anymore you should die it's Darwinism if
you see those people give them a [ __ ]
just lift up under their legs and just
drop backwards because they're not
supposed to be here anymore they've
taken up too many people's time in space
if you could play one video game for the
rest of your life which would it be NC
double-a college football do a new
version on there [ __ ] all you can go
2013 with updated rosters that someone
else does I don't have that much time
would you rather have the ability to be
invisible or have a clone of yourself to
go to work when you're hungover clone of
myself dude because then it just be like
man imagine those fights when you're
really having some self-loathing you're
like claw
oh and it gets out and you're like I can
put them up put them up I just
remembered something you said drunk to a
friend and I'm embarrassed by it I am
I'll do every every night at my house
would be like the ending of Rocky 3 you
know where I'd be sitting there and I'd
be like you want to ring the bell you
want me my clones are Thing Thing that's
every night at my house who's I knew is
just you are in the belly of my closet
[ __ ] connecting I mean I love him
somebody could do that painting with me
and myself and that old rock III stay on
board
clone me up